Oh ah that was close
uh ah I can't tell I don't have to watch
tick-tock videos I can just watch DVDs
screen
I haven't actually working sit set up
now so all right well I guess on episode
500 it will actually hit the corner
goddamn that it's distracting is it
gonna do alright without further ado
let's just jump into it for some reason
tic toc videos is still very much a
thing okay yes I'm talking right now
shut up no one knows why tic TOCs is
still the thing okay
tick tock memes this is what's gonna
destroy humanity 79 million subscribers
please subscribe as well first off I
gotta show you guys I don't remember if
I showed it before but this is the best
Tech Talk ever it's so accurate I love
it so good they hit or miss me it's
what's gonna kill us all
I bet you never miss huh got a boyfriend
I gave him I think
[Music]
really glad that tic TOCs have just
become more injured
I cannot it's so [ __ ] distracting
Jesus Christ I need to know like it
always looks I haven't in my peripheral
and it looks like it's gonna hit it hey
that's it I'm sorry guys this is too
much what can I change it to how about I
put on my own videos in that way I can
just copy strike myself
that'll is that less distracting for you
guys
oh I don't even know if that was good or
not but that drop though god damn and
the girl is good how about that
teenagers were too much spare time
fantastic you know I just realize it's
January I can put whatever I want in
this video it doesn't matter well I'm
watching a tick tock meme compilation I
mean you just watching yourself normally
I would just meme it and go like oh four
ad revenue but I mean it's January like
why am I here
what is support am i pathetic I got
nothing else to do I'm not addicted to
making shitty YouTube videos all right
let's keep jumping into it guys excited
for the next Tech Talk where's it gonna
be a hit or miss perhaps it's chuckle
worried I don't know oh my god was it
gonna be chugga-chugga chugga-chugga
chugga-chugga chugga-chugga
chugga-chugga whoa big chunga's what an
epic mean a life every time I don't
understand why it's a meme I still don't
get it I don't understand anything why
am I here
I love these it reminds me of that a
less sketch with a
Kassem G where they dance they have the
dance you've seen that your kids to one
okay mg he's old school the hit hit send
them in
[Music]
you
like all you all right it's funny I want
to see like a whole movie like this I
don't know why it's funny hahahaha
and then we go back to this
congratulations everyone you did it
can we leave some memes behind in 2018
police I'm begging you this one
goddammit this is the point oh why don't
I just watch this myself oh okay yeah
you want to sit through these do you
know how many bad ones I go through
humanity bad cringy pathetic ones that I
have to sit through trihard wanna be
funny kids you think I want to be here I
don't I'm that desperate stop
complaining this is me two weeks of
watching Ninja you have a name your
shirt don't even pretend to me that
you're not a ninja face this is me five
weeks on ninja I'm not seeing it up
Mumma guys there's not enough movement
please get it that was my impression
ninja this one is great whoever filmed
it I need that church I need that church
who filmed that I want to know legit
like where is that Jesus Jesus confirmed
this man
[Music]
everyone on this app is saying that
their gamer girls but they're actually
not I am a real gamer girl and I'm just
I don't know I don't
oh wow she is a real gamer girl she's
playing on an iPad a mobile game oh you
know she I knew she wasn't a real gamer
girl from this moment I saw that she
wasn't playing Lords mobile the most
epic video game of all time at least
play mafia city like a real gamer Jesus
Christ
smh all these fake-ass gamer girls don't
make me laugh Dora the explora
Oh whatever okay
one day in Norwegian we Norwegian
Norwegian Norwegian what is he trying to
do Norway Norway Norway this is my voice
five weeks so Norway I am an idiot
cuz I'm from Norway I am a fake Swede I
am the bad version of a Swedish person
that's right take the al-noor away you
suck I'm just kidding I'm kidding Norway
legit the last conversation I had with
my granddad on his deathbed he told me
was his plan on how we could invade
Norway so easily you just kept going dad
they have no defense and they have all
the oil just in case anyone is wondering
why I hate Norway so much
[Music]
I love these they're so I love I frickin
love come on they're funny where is that
from by the way wait it's a movie I
thought it was like a I thought it was
like a modern TV show or whatever
[Laughter]
hey this brings a whole new meaning to
this this is great oh there's more lines
don't turn this into vine is exactly how
Lily paws was created oh let's do it for
the vine guys let's do it for the vine
they got that a little bit inch of
famous that they should not have gone
and they just clawed to it like a
machine like a monster people need to
know mate but me and REE want you to
stop it stop it tick tock none of this I
want none of this yes this is what I'm
talking about
has she reacted to this clip like I want
them to remake it george w bush be like
no ain't having this
none of this it will just get to
monetize oh wait
it's January it doesn't matter press
play that's right everybody it's January
I can see what I want I can say the
n-word I don't want to okay I don't want
to I've changed I see this is great the
cross it's a little too slow to really
keep the same overlap but still it's
great nevertheless nine-year-olds
everybody I don't know if I should be
prouder this is me one day on Joe Joe's
you are guys this is me one week on
jerusalem this is me two weeks on joe
Josie was actually pretty accurate that
was pretty good how about that Wow well
done you get a bonus point alright so
I'm in calls I'm gonna see this just for
men alright this 2018 privilege you know
this is a joke now but it is gay
give it a couple months they said
they're gonna have to remove this brand
just for people for people
what about non people lore'l men experts
so you're saying women can't be experts
huh SMS L'Oreal shake you privilege oh
there you go that's the best tick-tock
of all time we found it everyone what in
the actual
[Music]
what is that I want it I want it finally
he's back making tic toc videos that's
awesome
welcome back laughs look hey guys the
rest of this tick tock is for people who
speak Turkish only so if you don't speak
Turkish you want to understand just keep
scrolling
gobble gobble gobble gobble gobble
gobble gobble gobble holy [ __ ] that's
racism and I will not stand here and
just listen to this I've said this
before
tick tock is racism what is tick tock
and is it safe the answer to that is no
it is extremely racism now that it's
January I can finally call this out okay
this is the level right now everyone
that's great you know it's January who
cares
it's in January you know what I'm gonna
say it's freaking January that's right
everybody it's good Jerry oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
alright good edit there that's great I
hope you guys had fun I had fun as well
no one asked ok well I don't care shut
up thank you guys for watching remember
to check out represent calm /pd pipe
that's right everybody we have merged
15% off go get that show your support
epic staff brofist